[Musique]
merci déchire on va continuer et on va
côte on va continuer ce soir avec jean
michel maire à jean michel maire on a
décidé de le piéger et on l'a mis j'ai
mis dans une loge d'un soir et jean
michel maire je vais demander de me
parler un petit peu des chroniques aubin
et vous voir vous allez voir que jean
michel maire c'est quand même un sacré
dans l'arbre sacré salo a volé je tenais
à vous lire le mot
regardez oui il y avait des caméras jean
michel maire non j'ai prétexté un projet
en fait de deuxième partie de soirée
et regardez jean michel maire il
fracasse tout le monde au nom même
aujourd'hui samedi avec iphone os mon
chéri justement je trouve exceptionnel
au stand lancer une nouvelle émission à
deux cellules sétois boire des coups de
fil facetime en direct nantes et sur
séville troisième partie de soirée
et c'est un peu sexe et je te vois
dedans grâce à moi mais je te vois avec
une meuf
or j'avais pensé avec la caroline
départs orange a pourtant su faire
adhérer qu'elle est jolie et sexy mais
je pense que alors je te jure je pense
tu veux trop la pécho donc c'est pas moi
j'ai dit si j'ai aimé tous les soirs
ensemble ça va faire des histoires puis
son mari et où c'est quoi l'enjeu
discutera après l'émission
oui mais comme l'été 2006 et où que ce
le fut mais c'est un tocard qui très
calme tu penses de montcalm saisie non
je suis dit ça comme ça j'imagine que
tout le monde
si je le faisais en attaque notamment
mis la pêcherie non sans appel qui n'est
pas fini le temps des vaches man city
l'attaquant à côté bmw n'a sûrement pas
ça je te mettrai nié avec daniel raunet
eric table après j'ai pensé à capucine
fous-moi labrador soit sam au silicone
non franchement non pourtant valérie
mammeri à ces nouveaux bleus qui a l'air
non tu es plus jamais rien eu lieu entre
moult des festivals eric valérie s est
une maman toi c'est mal à ses
spectateurs
nico est rigolo c'est que déjà vous
manquiez un bateau une fois un seul -
pas l'air d'être aussi très bien alors
je pense que la meilleure solution c'est
non
les stats et des radios lesquels pas le
seul truc qu'on starnab en restant
simple chat noir
bergie n'appelle pas de l'émission sur
eux si vite s'arrêter sur ses stars
compagnie aux personnes que
folie dans une amérique n ont pas du
tout dit l'adage
honnêtement j'ai partir un peu cher et
je penserai à côté pour aller chez un
comique un chroniqueur va voir toujours
tirer la couverture à elle moi je moi je
da tandis que la bes de voilà retour
attendu de travailler avec elle bah quoi
parce qu'il est rentable et les trains
parce que bon jour et que vous fassiez
empire tous les deux mois ce que ça fait
là
et puis après on nous dit que c'est mort
donc toi tu veux pas du tout être
acquérir un bel écart que tu va proposer
moment non non non c'est pas enfin mes
choix mais en deuxième mais je crois pas
qu'elle a des qualités comme oui mais à
l'égalité merrill et les résultats sont
là dès qu'elle a un truc c'est l'instant
où les animations pour les maisons le
passionnant même à côté attend tous les
gens il était une fois ci non je fais
comme ça tu vois comment l été c était
trop calmes autres ça ce sont des
abeilles voilà un festival seront pour
cauet
melvin thomas était meilleur qu'il n'y a
rien
25 il ya des banlieues toujours été cool
je m'étonne tout le temps de chauffe a
inventé un truc j'ai crevé à fabien
pieds nus comme ça en français et en
piste ça n'arrive pas à les laisser ma
faute si ça marche grâce à elle donc
après cette voie voire un peu engageants
pas de ses murs il urge déjà de données
transmises mais c'est au-dessus telenor
a franchement j'adore j'adore je peux
pas croire non c'est bidon touche mes
mains touche b - la troupe label jour il
bosse et je sais pas ce qui me choque le
plus maintenant
non mais moi je voulais écrire et nous
que j'en ai fait des tonnes voilà je
pense marmen est-ce que je dernière mais
il est vraiment comme ça
[Applaudissements]
j'ai répété plusieurs fois j'adore
hainaut ces mois-là fait de la radio
mais ce soit à bout là vous devez alors
je vais laisser la parole à la
principale intéressée
quand même et léo la peau qui s'en est
pris que je l'embrasserai g l'ombre à sa
main en battant oui parce que tu vas
rester à ta place
non mais parce qu'on est on fait de la
télé là il ya un moment donné là c'est
plus de la télé quoi mais là non non non
mais t'as gueule à un moment donné tu
vois là vraiment puisque les gens volent
que je me vénère voilà je vais me weiler
vraiment je crois que toi et moi on
était potes ont des pages sera plus
jamais jamais je ne me serais permis de
parler comme toi / sur ce ton comme ça
joue pas la personne âgée la qui pue de
la gueule d'un moment ça va sembler
l'insulté tout on démarre mon métier
fait travailler moi tu as tu des x men
on vient de faire un bisou mais il nous
faut aimer regarder en direct décoller
j'ai envie chine en soirée il se fait
passer pour mon pote soit disons sors ma
chance c'est moi qui l'ait reims à
chaque fois et là tu m'en met plein la
gueule à l'antenne pour que tu es une
émission de venir
j'essaie d'y jouer de proches devaient
faire un pilote avec toi j'ai pas dit
qu'on voulait faire un pilote
ouais bravo
non mais c'est une caméra cachée on ne
veut pas dire est qu est ce qu on va on
va se retrouver dans un instant les
chiroux va voir on va essayer de calmer
droit on se retrouve dans un instant
dans la grande race râler chéri on est
en direct
vous voyez les gens me parlent et il ya
le facebook live il a tout de suite avec
qui qui va faire le facebook j'ai vu
tout à l'heure mais c'est d'abord un
message et gilles verdez et on va
essayer d'aller chercher noraogo fois tu
en as
aujourd'hui on soit deux minutes c'est
parti a tout de suite lancé la pub
lancée la première fois il m'a trompée
qu'est ce qui se passe je l'aimé trop
peu hyper mal salut moi c'est pas
correct d'avoir montré sa série non mais
enora et ce qu'elle peut rentrer ce que
vous avez quelque chose d'un petit
cadeau pour une aura quelque chose bah
oui j'avais prévu et laura est ce
qu'elle peut rentrer doha elle a pas
envie et nos rares
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et l'on a fait vibrer la dois aller
l'argent mais je pensais pas le millième
de ce que j'ai dit me suis emballé c'est
à cause aussi cyril jouerions discute
comme ça comme des cons et voilà
franchement je t'adore tu sais même plus
et l'on veut pas
et quoi jeter dans la gueule ouais non
non et non à risque
oui ouais
voilà ou alors est ce que je lui dis oui
de plus moi qui t'ai piégée
[Applaudissements]
oui
c'est laura cap les jeux jean michel
naud j'en dors pas vous étiez vraiment
voulions loin puisque nous au départ 200
caméras pour les piéger exactement et
donc vos visites sortir tout seul ou
presque j'ai pas c'est pas bon pointu
médicis il soit futur masi balance
puisque la france mais je lâche et les
beats et que j'ai été amené quand je
suis rentré chez moi je lui dis [ __ ]
mais ça craint ce qu'elle va prendre ça
en pleine gueule je n'étais pas dire la
preuve qu'ils ont renvoyée au moins
quinze message en disant deux minutes
après la caméra tout de suite on dit que
c'est des conneries que c'est faux et
puis après quand je lis ça tarde à neige
mais il aura la gueule qu'elle faisait
jeudi c'est le prendrais bravo edwards a
capté la jambe
[Applaudissements]